i watched the tyson fight last night
and dude i was most excited about seeing
um
jake floyd against uh
what's his name nate uh nate robinson
and dude i thought nate robinson was
gonna whoop his ass honestly
because i've fought black dudes before
and they they'll be jazz
and so i thought that was kind of how it
was gonna shake out
but damn bruh jake paul
he's man he seemed legit just
it was hard to get a real take on it
because nate was just
coming at him
nate kind of had that bulldog like a
bulldog with a um
ear infection you ever see that dog and
he trying to bite you but he also
he don't aim correctly because his
you know his equilibrium is on uh
you know it's got a bad wheel so he's
biting but he's
you know he missing to the left every
time he tried to
you know to teeth you down to gum you up
and and jake paul he really
he made that dude pay
he made him pay i mean he put him out
son
so you got to give props to both those
dudes for getting out there that [ __ ]
looks
scary them dudes start throwing them
fists man
um
so yeah i i enjoy watching it i mean the
whole i didn't like all the rapping and
[ __ ]
i'm like what is all this [ __ ] i felt
like i was trapped in a net in a
nightclub in jacksonville florida
i was like this [ __ ] is crazy people are
fighting
a lot of smoke in the air a lot of dance
like uh
just one dude dancing by himself it
definitely had a very jacksonville vibe
to it
um but uh so
what when watching the tyson think go i
wasn't excited about it
i i i watched it on um stream east or
whatever
where you get the free stream pirated
i'm the captain now i did the pirate and
why was that pirate
you know i stole the [ __ ] i stole it
and yeah i didn't i just felt like uh
i don't know if i didn't feel like it
was for me
i thought the ring looked like a video
game
they really went for this video game
look like complete black in the
background
uh i don't even know if they need it at
the staples center i wonder what the
cost was of that
because you got to shell out them
duckets
you want the staple center you could
have done that and um
you know you could have done that at a
staples
at an abandoned staples you know one of
those staples they got looted out there
in los angeles or portland you could
have done that on damn aisle six on
envelopes
but i just don't know what the cost was
to do it at the actual big staples
center
but i guess it does add a different
mystique to it
and as viewers held we don't even know
if they really did it at the staples
center they could have been showing it
from the helicopter and not doing it
they could have done that anywhere uh
what else i watched it what did i feel
like i felt like
it was exactly what i thought it was
gonna be i'm glad i didn't pay for it
um i wanted them there was too many
rules going into it
and there was too much hugging
mostly the thing about the tyson fight
it made me remember to call my
grandfather
and my grandfather is dead
so i just prayed a little
and uh almost ouija boarded him but i
didn't even honestly know him that well
and he was my step-grandfather and he
used to take us on a motorcycle
and we used to catch fresh catfish and
he would have him you know he put him on
that stringer and i'd put him over my
shoulder
and i barely had a shoulder probably
four years old hell half the fish was
older than me i caught
you know i'd have 19 years worth of fish
on my back and i'm just strapped in
[ __ ] on
and he would just let me sit on the back
of the motorcycle hold on to him with
one arm and just
you know shoulder a a little batch of
bull heads
spoon river catfish solder them over my
other shoulder and just
[Music]
and then get over you know get back to
the hall back to the house but
but yeah what else i remember you know
it was
jones jr looked scared or just more
nervous he definitely looked gassed out
pretty quick
you know and i've seen senior citizen
fight
you know in my neighborhood when i was
growing up this man mr polito got in a
fight and uh
he got thrown into a ditch fire
by milford king and milford died
but this is when he was um alive
and milford was our school bus driver he
was shirtless
and a lot of people think oh school bus
drivers should have a shirt on well
hell if they should baby boy you know a
lot of school bus drivers they don't
need a shirt
you don't need a shirt to drive a bus
that's a damn myth
you know that's a methamphetamine bro
that's people smoking ideas that aren't
aren't facts and
uh and milford was red-headed
and he had red chest hair and back hair
and he probably weighed about
305 pounds 378 pounds
and he spoke i thought he spoke a
different language but he just couldn't
talk
well you know i think they probably
taught him about three quarters of the
alphabet
in the last quarter it was just
i mean he was just damn vanna whiting
out there he's just spinning letters he
don't know what the hell is going on
he'd put a seven in the middle of a
sentence he didn't you know sometime
he'd throw a damn uh
an asterisk in the middle of a damn word
he don't you know he didn't know he
wasn't fully
equipped um
you know if knowledge was a 18 wheeler
this dude probably had about a
this dude has seven tires on him he was
that kind of guy
but he fist fought this old man named mr
polito
and threw him in a ditch fire in our
neighborhood
when they were both pretty much near
senior citizenship
and when i saw this fight that's the
first thing i thought of i said i've
seen they should put a
you know put a damn fire in the middle
and let these dudes [ __ ] get irish
bruh
because they run this weak ass you know
i mean that's the thing about when old
when old people fight of different
cultures they fight differently
you know you got two old old brothers
out here fighting and they they've
actual fists fighting they got it all
gloves and everything
you throw two old white dudes out there
somebody's ending up in a damn fire
so it's cultural baby good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah